president sippy cup joe biden is in
belgium today meeting with nato
and european leaders after spending the
weekend in the uk
where he met with the queen all of this
coming
ahead of biden's highly anticipated
meeting with
russian president vladimir putin on
wednesday but
he's not going to be doing a joint press
conference because it's not going to be
a competition he said
all right here with reaction to all of
this plus the latest controversies with
the royal family editor-at-large at the
dailymail.com great paper
uh piers morgan all right first we got
to deal with one issue
i watched the day you walk off the show
and we've had a great relationship over
the years we really have and i'm a fan
of yours
you have the highest ratings you ever
have in the history of the show
um and i wanted you back on
now that you're not back on there when
are you coming back on the air
you you're born to do this well
i'm definitely having some very
interesting conversations sean as you
can probably
imagine uh there are lots of people that
wouldn't mind a piece of the action
for somebody who traveled the ratings on
that morning show in five years which is
what we did i mean there was a weird
surreal kind of day on the day i left
where having reached a ratings high
normally you would get invited to
a boardroom and presented with a
carriage clock but i got invited to
either apologize
to meghan markle for believing her or
leave the building so i decided to leave
the building all right so here's what
i'd like to understand
so megan and harry they go on one of the
biggest platforms
that you could ever go on and that's
oprah winfrey they give this bombshell
interview
where they accused without mentioning by
name although they clarified
it wasn't the queen so that kind of
leaves
prince harry's brother and father
hanging out to dry
as being racist and yet on the one hand
he's calling the first amendment freedom
of speech bonkers
but he's willing to use the first
amendment along with his wife to trash
his own family i found that quite
hypocritical
piers morgan yeah i think it's
completely ridiculous
these two want to have their royal cake
and eat it they're very happy to trade
off their royal titles
the duke and duchess of sussex when it
comes to negotiating
hundreds of millions of dollars with
companies like spotify and netflix
uh but at the same time they want the
right to trash the royal family and the
monarchy
and therefore the queen who's the head
of the monarchy on global television
repeatedly now they keep doing this
and i think it's sickening to people
over here
in the uk you know we've just seen the
queen with the american president joe
biden
and you can see what a magnificent lady
she is she's been on the
throne for nearly seven decades she's a
remarkable person
who puts duty first and it seems to me
that megan and harry
don't even understand the concept of
duty it is rankly hypocritical
i think it sticks in people's gullets
over here
and uh in relation to that interview we
now know that
there were at least 17 things that came
out of meghan markle's mouth
which have now been proven to be untrue
so
i don't know what point i'm allowed to
not have to apologize for just believing
somebody
who is palpably a liar it is a
farcical situation and of course as with
all these situations
at the moment the council culture
twitter mob
come for you and they say well if you
don't believe meghan markle
you are a racist to which i say i've
never said a racist thing
about meghan markle or anybody else it
has nothing to do
with her skin color and everything to do
with her
inability to tell the truth uh and her
rank hypocrisy
and i think it's time those two gave up
their titles uh
stopped whining 24 7 uh and trying to
take a leaf out of the
the book of the queen whose name whose
nickname
lillabet they've hijacked for their
daughter take a little tip from the
queen
less is more you know if you want to be
a royal
a member of the royal family less is
more we're hearing too much of your
yapping
too much of your whining it's time to
pipe down
i am concerned though too megan also
complained to your employer
and to the government now
my reading of the laws in britain a show
like mine
where i'm a talk show host i do news
straight news
investigative reporting opinion culture
sports i do it all
i'd have problems being a broadcaster in
great britain is that true
yeah it's very difficult we are
government regulated
uh there's a regulatory body called
ofcom whose only job it is
is to basically boss around people uh on
the airwaves
and tell us what we can and can't say
very different
to what happens in the united states
where you're covered by
the first amendment the same first
amendment that prince harry
can't stomach because he only wants the
right for the media to say nice things
about him
not to hold him to account um and it
makes life very difficult
um but also i think at the center of all
this sean
it's something that i know you've done
lots of coverage on which is this
epidemic of cancer culture which is this
sort of
very small but vocal group of illiberal
liberals i call them the new fascists
who want to tell us how to lead our
lives how to speak
how to think what to find funny what we
can enjoy on television at the movies
you know what historical figures we can
appreciate or not appreciate
and if you deviate one iota from their
woke world view you must be shamed
vilified and canceled
and we're seeing it happening again and
again and again
and corporate institutions have to stand
up to this nonsense
you know i discovered after i left uh
the morning show over here for example
the meghan markle personally contacted
my boss demanding
all sorts of things including an apology
that can't be right
somebody like meghan markle a public
figure thinks she has the right to
dictate
uh the freedom of speech and the freedom
of expression and opinion
of broadcasters like me or indeed
yourself
on national television but that's where
we've got to and it's a pretty scary
state of affairs
but i think it's it's certainly a hill
worth dying for when it comes to
protecting
freedom of speech i want to get your
perception of joe biden because he went
to this g7 summit he's got this this
meeting with putin coming up
and my perception is and i'm very
outspoken about it is that he
is weak he is frail he is struggling
mightily cognitively i run tapes of him
from 2012 and 2016 and today
he you know he he's a shell of his
former self in my opinion and i think
the tapes speak volume
volumes uh what are the perception of
our friends across the pond
think the perception of president biden
and his trip to the uk for the g7 summit
was it was all fine
uh it wasn't the kind of noise and chaos
and unpredictability
of a president trump visit which
personally i rather missed actually i
was not enlivened
because i missed a learning affair get
together and
say boring platitudes i think there's
also a wider issue
uh sean about president biden is i think
he sees his job his role
so calm everything down as if somehow
that's enough and i don't think it is
you know when you're dealing with china
we're dealing with russia when you're
dealing with nato
when you're dealing with you know every
issue out there from the pandemic to
climate change whatever
i'm not sure people want to calm america
that isn't taking
dynamic proactive action and what the
people liked or didn't like donald trump
what i did like about him was his awful
personality
enabling him to cut through a lot of
bureaucracy and cut to the quick about
issues and nato was a good example you
know they're all with nato now everybody
knows
that most nato countries don't pay their
bills we know that
because donald trump showed a light on
that iniquity and thought it was unfair
that america should carry
the can for so many underpaying european
countries
he was absolutely right about that he
was also right about the threat of china
go back two or three years and joe biden
doesn't think china is a threat
suddenly he does well you know donald
trump has been calling out china for 30
years to my
uh certain knowledge so there were lots
of things which i felt that donald trump
didn't get enough credit for
which joe biden because he's a liberal
and a democrat president
gets too much credit for now and i don't
think he's held to the same account by
the media
in america that donald trump was and i
think that's just a plain
and obvious fact and that is not good
for the us media
you should be unafraid to hold your own
your own liberal democrat president to
the same ferocious account that he held
donald trump
otherwise you're just as biased as i
always hear them say
fox news is uh you know of course
there are more opinions besides sean
hannity's peers get back on the air my
humble
advice to to a friend um you were born
to do this i suspect you'll be back
sooner than
then you're letting on i hope that's the
case uh you're always welcome on this
show thanks
thanks for being with us john always a
pleasure thank you very much for having
me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else